Dias
nice Leute ich bin h die Dias am
raustrappen und diesmal ist es mehr als
einer um viel ins Bett zu gehen ist
irgendwie trippy lol was kan da gerade
für ein
[Musik]
Trommelwirbel servus Kids und herzlich
willkommen auch an die Zuschauer von
Logo zu der Folge numero 12 der
Minecraft Legend und heute
sind wir natürlich immer noch im dritten
Teil von nächtliche verballerung nachts
um 3 Uhr aufnehmen und ja sind immer
noch fleißig am am hasseln wir haben ja
auch noch sieben Gold ne das was ist mit
dem Gold da drüben wurde es mal gebrannt
oder hier oder hier ja ja ich ich wollte
mir gerade holzspitzhacken machen ich ma
jetzt zwei eisenspitzhacken und fang an
in die Richtung hier hinten zu
meinen schon das erste Zucker gewachsen
perfekt oh nice das geht schnell und ich
starte schon wieder zum Anfang der Folge
den ersten nächsten
Tagebucheintrag ist hier irgendwo
der vierte Tag wir
beginnen in den drin wir beginnen
fleißig zu meinen zack noch ein bisschen
geh also wir wenn wir jetzt doch ein
bisschen mehr Gold finden können wir uns
dann auch theoretisch mal opapfel machen
lass doch mal direkt schon mal
brauchstand craften oder was meinst Du
ja okay dann crafte ich jetzt mal
unseren brauchstand zack bum ich glaube
die macht man so oh bitte kein lohstop
machen ja brwing stand nice okay und
mein Plan war so dass wir dann
irgendwann nachts mal an die Oberfläche
gehen und uns mit Hilfe der
Pilze fermentierte spinnenaugen machen
dafür brauchen wir auch Zucker dafür
haben wir zuckerr das ist gut das trifft
sich gut und daraus dann Tränke der
Schwäche machen dafür brauchen wir
nämlich keine netherwartzen und dann
können wir Schwäche auf unser Schwert
machen und ja e auch ganz coole Sache
könn mal gerne in die Kommentare
schreiben was ihr davon haltch ich
brauch ja noch es gibt ja auch kaum
Leute die sich mit dem modpack
beschäftigen können weil wie wird sich
mit dem modpack beschäftigen wenn es
geschlossen ist ja gut stimmt auch aber
man kann sich auf jeden Fall Tränke auf
die Schwerter machen und dann hätten wir
halt Schwerter die immer so ein
schwächeeffekt auf den Gegner packen
wenn wir die Treffen wä eigentlich ganz
cool sag mal an man kann doch auch aus
Redstone Fackeln machen oder ja Redstone
Fackeln ja gell haben wir willst du das
machen das ist schwachsin die Leuchten
nicht so stark mach dir lieber normale
Fackeln kann dir auch Kohle geben und
alles ja cool dann gib mal Kohle die
Leuchten nicht so stark was ist das denn
e was ist sind nur die sind auch nur für
Signale und sowas da ich weiß ja aber
was ist Redstone bit eigentlich für ein
behindertes
item hast du mir Kohle gedroppt oder
ja habe ich nice habe ich die auch ja jo
Alter richtig viel Kohle Mann Alter ich
bin gerade so am am abdancen hier du
bist da am abfeppen Alter täusch jetzt
mal nicht über die Tatsachen Weg könn
ich dich schlagen würde ich dich
schlagen ach nee kannst du aber nicht
you can see
me Fragen auf dazugekommen sind okay ne
Z Leute haben das retweetet das bringt
uns nicht sehr viel doch mit jedem
Retweet kann man ein Paket für hung
notleidende in
ruandaau gewisser s fragt warum nehmt
ihr 2 Uhr morgens
auf da muss dir erstmal sagen mein
lieber sortex du bist falsch informiert
es ist mittlerweile 4 ja das
ist bevor du hier mit falschen Fakten
kommst lern die Fakten lern sie
auswendig Bo ist das
schwierig nice so läuft das ich hab
gehört wir ich meine jetzt hier wirklich
alles ich B auf Kohle gestoßen perfekt
das das eigentlich mega cooler Trick
dass man mit mit den Fackeln so den
gravel raushaut ne
ja ich bin jetzt auf Bedrock Höhe ich
werde mich dann hier jetzt durch durch
Strip mein
oder auf Bedrock Höhe ja Nein di gibt
nur bis gewissen Höhe B nicht mehr aber
hier sind sehr viele Ressourcen Kohle
und sowas ja gut aber di sind eigentlich
das Ziel ne ich fin ja auch überhaupt
keine motherfucking Dias Leute was ist
da
los in drei Folgen farming welchees Höhe
sagst du 14 du schau schau einfach noch
mal ins Minecraft
Wick
lol
lolcft Minecraft ficki weil der dem geh
das sollten wir uns öfter machen muss
ich mein PC nicht während der Aufnahme
belasten krass belasten mit Internet
Explorer oder wahrscheinlich benutzt
Internet Explorer
ne benutzt du Internet Explorer nein
Alter woll schon sagen gib mal
bitte also laut es lädt gerade warte dr
mal BR da schreib abhöhe
14 BR da und ich glaub am am häufigsten
von 9 bis 12 oder so ne am hfigen von 9
bis 12 dann sind wir auch mit ze
eigentlich sa gut dabei sich richtig gut
dabei ich mE hat einfach so viel
Cobblestone Leute es tut richtig weh ja
wollen wir so eine Verbrennungsanlage
haben wir Kaktus oder sowas Kaktus ach
kann man ein Kaktus auch Items kaputt
machen oder wie ja ich ich habe
natürlich ein Kaktus dabei diger das ist
klar okay dann lass nicht entgehen
einfach so ein Kaktus mitzunehmen ne du
kannst einfach ein Lava einal platzieren
ich habe ein Lava bucket ja dann mach
hier in die Ecke ein komm hier hier
hinten komm da
ja warte hier mach den zweief damit so
warte warte nicht dass das da unten
rausfließ warte klär das kurz die
Situation von unten ab
was da ja okay jetzt wunderbar perfekt
jetzt kan auch den ganzen Kel ver ich
sehe schon komm Team Log verbrennt den
ganzen kobbel und amende brauchen wir
irgendwo kobbel ja also gut ein kobbel
soll jetzt nicht mangeln in dieser Welt
also guck um überall kobbel poeller
kobbel da kobbel sogar richtiger Kel ich
ma das mal zur Absicherung ich bau da
mal so dort drüber eine trap baust du
nur um sicher zu gehen eine trap Alter
bist du ein trap lordord oder
wie ch dich du weg weg we Redstone mit
guck was da
passiert zack le also wir hatten ja
schon di gefunden aber leider war das so
eine richtig erbärmliche diquelle mit
nur einem einzigen man sich so denkt
diger warum existierst du warum hat
deine Mutter dich das war dieser eine
Elite Block unter ganz vielen
eliteblock ist das jetzt jetzt unsere
letzte Folge war ja genau wir
produzieren drei Folgen vor eventuell
melde ich mich dann auch mit einem Vlog
aus Köln wieder je
nachdem schauen wir einfach mal gibt's
neue Fragen auf Twitter keine neuen
reingekommen doch es gibt
neue@ Rex HD fragt denke ich mir ger
nicht aus übrigens sondern vkommen
begründet was fragt der Gute denn ich
muss gerade mal ganz genau
hinschauen er
fragt werdet ihr euch Tränke machen was
sagen wir dazu haben wir schon
beantwortet klar letzte Folge klar
machen wir uns Tränke Tränke machen wir
ja ich Leute ich hör auf zu reden jetzt
weil ganz ehrlich wenn ich schon
anfangen irgendwelche fiktiven Twitter
fragenstelle auszudenken und dann denke
ich kann mit meinem aktuellen Geistes
Gemü Zustand noch irgendwie mir eine
Frage aus den Fingern saugen was
natürlich überhaupt nicht der Fall ist
jetzt hast du den einal aber ich habe
nämlich eine Wasserquelle gefunden ich
auch
nice ich habe auch noch zwei aler ich
kann ja ger mal paar wasserquen ah ja da
bist du ja übrigens hi bin übrigens am
an der Wurzel der Wasserquelle hier oben
hier oben hier oben hier unten ist auf
jeden Fall auch noch eine warte ich mach
die dicht warte so
okay Bo nehmich gerade voll fresh am
Haven das Eisen
ab guck mal hier drüben ja Dias nice oh
was habe ich hier schönes gefunden ein
einfach hier an der Oberfläche und
richtig viel
Gold wieder nur ein einziger Leute ihr
wollt uns doch ich ich
Brae die wollen uns irgendwie verarschen
Leute ne ein einzer di warum frage ich
mich warte wir können erstmal den Schild
zubauen ich darf jetzt nicht nicht zu
weit in dieses Höhlensystem h reinappen
sonst ja aber lieber wieder weiteräe das
Loh mehr jetzt die letzte Zeit noch ja
ich mache auch ich hole kurz drüber noch
das
Gold mal wir sind sogar noch ganz gut im
Rennen wir sind Dritter ja ist so ne
also kann keiner sagen dass wir
irgendwie fget sind Dritter
es wird immer mehr Gold vielleicht
vielleicht kriegen wir irgendwann hin
uns opapfel zu machen wie viel braucht
man für ein opapfel 72 Gold ne ja ja
SMer auf dem guten Weg würde ich sagen
bisher 15 oder so ist das ich find aber
ich finde es läuft eigentlich auch ganz
gut bei uns jetzt sind wieder wir sind
wieder Z im ren ja ja auf jeden Fall ich
weiß nicht aber hier ist so eine geile
Höhle nein warte hier habe ich den di
rausgenommen ist hier keine Dias mehr
ist wier ich mach dein Strip meingang
raus es ist einfach wieder locker wieder
ein einzelner Diamant lol die Gänger
hast du ja aber nicht angelegt da sind
ja viel zu viele Gänge die ganzen
Quergänge da ja doch doch habe ich die K
wie komme ich da zurück zu den Basis
m wo bist du wir machen mal zu so bin da
gerade ich bin da gerade bei der hier
ja hier bin ich vor dir ja vor dir ja da
hinten okay ganz einfach du guckst mich
an so wo ist
[Musik]
der Achtung Loch im Boden ichinesetzt
Loch im Boden schnell behoben einfach
hier rechts in diese Richtung ein dahin
oder dahin eine Richtung check das
ab leute zias es geht
voran in die andere Richtung in andere
richtungcken and Richtung anderen
Richtung weiß du ich das
mein mit und Schilder das du bist nicht
ganz Dichtung in dein
Kopf noch mehr Eisen
nice nices Eisen Eisen habe jetzt auch
echt
muss man
sagen Leute man muss einfach mal ein
bisschen mit Gewissenhaftigkeit Farmen
so muss man einfach sagen bisschen mit
Gewissenhaftigkeit Farmen ihr können
auch gerne farmtipps irgendwie in die
Kommentare schreiben wenn ihr sowas
benut
xray xray habe ich ja schon in der
ersten Folge von unseren nchtlichen
vorproduziererei angewendet GG Fackel
bleibt da hat super funktioniert ihr
habt gesehen also x war auf jeden Fall
am Laufen in der Aufnahme ich wurde
immer noch nicht gebannt wieder noch
irgendwie jemand irgendwie was machen
gegen mich
oder ne du bist unbesiegbar irgendwie
habe ich nicht das Gefühl dass da jemand
noch noch irgendwie kein Respekt vor mir
hätte ich hab auch ich Klatsche mir
Leute wenn es nach oben geht wenn wir
irgendwann mal fighten gegen anymore
dann Klatsche ich mir einfach echt mal
einfach mal hier schön Forcefield rein
fly Hack und REC haacks und dann geht's
ab ganz ehrlich boah das wä so lustig
schreibt mal in die Kommentare ob ihr
das sehen wollt wie ich einfach g wie
ich einfach gegen animore Hacke schreibt
mal bitte in die Kommentare das
interessiert mich mega verlaufen ob ihr
sowas lustig finden würdet schreibt mal
rein verlaufen jetzt mich bitte hier
raus he da hinten hin bist du behind ja
da wenn ich da jetzt weiterlufe ja Nein
komm her komm
her
da oder du sagst du sagst da geh jetzt
hier rüber wenn das jetzt nicht das Ziel
ist Alter warte oder ne nee ne ne ne ne
ne ne hier hinten geht dahin hey da komm
komm raus komm raus es ist doch gar
nicht so guck mal hier da in diese
Richtung und in diese Richtung sind
stripmeingänge Logo komm her so diese
rechts links stripingänge da vorne ist
es zu Ende das heißt wir kommen aus der
Richtung zack okay dann ich da jetzt
aber ich gehe da jetzt bis ans Ende okay
ja
ja bin ich jetzt ja ach da vorne ja okay
hat sich gerade erledigt get W by brain
Alter really really though 3 Uhr morgens
darf ich bei meinem eigenen brain sein
wir sind schon Hal wir sind schon 3:3
wann soll ich bitte aufstehen morgen das
kann nicht sein oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott wen man halt Youtuber
ist und nebenbei noch ein normales Leben
führt wo man irgendwie mal deswegen habe
ich ein Vorteil weil ich ke normalesben
um 11 mal wach sein muss dann hat man
echt ein Problem Leute weil dann nimmt
man Nacht zum:3r auf muss morgens 11
wieder wach sein sein GI 7 Stunden
Schlaf gehen fit Alter kann man nichts
sagen genau das ist eigentlich
chillig aber einfach um vi ins Bett zu
gehen ist irgendwie
trippy lol was kan für Trommelwirbel h
lol kam kriegst jetzt schon
Trommelwirbel ja ohne Witz da kam
Trommelwirbel Leute was ist das was war
das einf nachum Hal vi so trumel
Dias
nice Leute ich bin hier die Dias am
raustrappen und diesmal ist es mehr als
einer 1 2
3 4 5 damit haben wir insgesamt sieben
Dias Logo
ja wie vi haben wie vi wie viel haben
wir
sieben wir sind nun in
Besitz und
s Dias schreibst in die gruppenkonfi
oder wie nein in mein Tagebuch kann ich
das Signieren und dann immer nochreiben
glaube
nicht glaube
nicht ich habe schon 21
Level machen
men men das ganz anders machen und zwar
so
zack
weiter
Leute
LAV will Lava
sehenation beim auf oh mein Gott Leute
was ist los mit meinemin wir haben s
Leute wir Trappen die Dias
[Musik]
Weg doch zum Erfolg auch wenn ich Gefühl
dass wir irgendwie eher Sperlich
bestückten Höhle
sind wir können eich auch mal hier
drüben reinschauen da kann es
theoretisch auch Dias
geben es gibt keine weiteren Fragen so
da hinten ist eine Höhle ich weiß nicht
gehen wir hin ja gehen hin da gehen mal
hin ich habe üb auch noch mal Wasser ne
also falls wir nachher noch die Quelle
brauchen sind hier Dias nee hier sind
leider keine Dias K kurz hier in die
Wand kloppen was finden bei Redstone
zufig hab auch gerade eben gefunden auch
wenn es meiner Meinung nach nicht stimmt
dass man iger Dias bei Redstone findet
nein bei Lava habe ich mal gehört ja das
stimmt glaub ich alles nicht also wenn
man das Minecraft wirklich sagt wenn ich
mich nicht recht erinnere dass das alles
so urban myths sind die nicht stimmen
und die einfach ja falsch sind so die
sie aber irgendwie halten ich meine
haben auch ewig alle geglaubt dass
irgendwie goldschwert eine bessere
Kritchance hat als ein Holzschwert WE
irgendaub habe ich nicht gewusst bis
dann Dom irgendwie von N das mal
wiederlegt hat Professor Dom übrigens
Professor ein Wissenschaftler von Welt
in der eulenwirtschaft der weiß
wie die Eulen fliegen ohne Spaß um die
Uhrzeit sind wir einfach des todeschard
wieso wieso wieso wir die gravity jetzt
ger nicht auf den gravel es ist doch
gravityv oh mein Gott die gravity wirk
einfach nicht auf ist einfach das ist
eigentlich auch so Minecraft den niemand
kennt um 3 Uhr 3:31 Uhr wirkt die
gravity undon gravel nicht meh einfachak
Leute ich Geruch einfach mal probiert
mal sowas spielt malch Minecraft eine
jetzt noch in mein Inventar sensationell
diese ganzen Pixelblöcke verweben sich
mit eurem Bewusstsein und Bild irgendwie
so ein Plasma und ihr seid dieses Plasma
ich hab das wertvollste Zeug jetzt aus
der Kiste erstmal genommen ja genau
und damit ist erstmal hier kurz mal Tag
Tag 4 ist abgeschlossen wir beginnen
fleißig zu meinen möge Jesus mit uns
sein wir sind im Besitz von S Dias der
Tag hat
ein schönes Ende
genommen in Klammern 3 Uhr morgens oder
3: 31 Uhr noch eine Notiz ja an an an
Minecraft die wie nennt sich das
Anziehung nee
die die Gravitation von ne die ach Leute
ich mal hier raus aus dem Ding das wir
mir zu bunt
ja okay Notiz Notiz an Notiz an die
Minecraft
Minecraft Minecraft Seite
Wiki die anzieh nee die schwer Spin
Spinne wür ich doch gerne mal Töten
von muss ich sagen W funkt morgens
nicht
ist irgendwo eine Spinne
bitte beheben wir nehmen nämlich schön
viel die ganze schön die ganze Seite mit
damit wir uns D noch paar Bögen machen
können weil W enchanter haben machen wir
uns auch mal ein paar Power Bögen und
damit wir dann unsere Gegner noch besser
weg blackern können okay perfekt unser
Buch hat jetzt schon drei Seiten ist
ordentlich geführt das # Log Tagebuch
fühlt sich langsam schreibt mal ein paar
Ideen wir schreiben eine Fanfiction rein
nein okay die Folge ist jetzt aber auch
schon überzogen dann war
das können theoretisch ein bisschen
machen ich meine die anderen machen auch
40 Minuten Folgen al kein Problem wie
wie du wie du Bock hast also wenn du
sagst ja es reicht jetzt es reicht alles
klar Logo reicht jetzt langsam gen ich
will aber no weiter
mein warte war warte kom wir beenden die
Folge
zusammen wir beenden die zusammen ich
komme rüber zu dir Schatzi okay wo bist
du Schatzi schick mir ein fotoick mir
Foto von ich hasse Schlager Leute ich
hasse das nur nachts um 4R kann das
irgendwie in meinen Kopf Einzug finden
wenn ich einfach geistig nicht mehr
existiere geil Alter ist das was ist das
was Leute ist das
was wunderbar das ist das ist se
wunderbar es ist se wunderbar okay Leute
Schluss mit verballerung die nächsten
Folgen dürfen nach mal aufgenommen
werden wir dürfen nicht mehr Nacht 12
aufnehmen ab jetzt wird mittags
aufgenommen und wir haben kurz Revie
passieren lassen unsere Dias hier wir
haben unser Gold im im stash behalt das
alles im inventarsisen
warte nimm das Eisen noch mit rein ne ja
habe ich okay und dann Leute sehen wir
uns in der nächsten Folge wieder
mülleimal funktioniert alles perfekt bis
dann haut rein macht's gut und ciao und
ciao